you sent me the screener and i watched
it and now i realize
how hard you worked on that
and i know what a perfectionist you are
and i know that you love wrestling so
much you've wrestled with major
wrestlers from the wwe
you've been following it your whole life
i can't imagine that it's that easy for
you to let things go when you're
wrestling on set in scenes and you're
doing something and you're like
is does that look real let me see that
like were you were you so involved in a
lot of those um sequences those fight
sequences i was incredibly involved i
wanted to bring on
people i mean we had luke hawks who's an
independent professional wrestler he was
says sensibly like uh like on arrow we
had an ultra archery consultant he's
like the the wrestling consultant
but all the backstage stuff the way that
wrestlers would talk to each other the
fact that they
communicate with the referees
um
and that the referee is communicating
with someone backstage et cetera et
cetera like all of that stuff that's
that nobody knows
because no one from the wrestling world
wants to talk about it because it's
kayfabe
right which is the title of the first
episode which is the parts it's the
parts of the wrestling world that you
just don't talk to the public about
right it's like a magician doesn't
give away his tricks
and i've been so fortunate to be
backstage at
at a giant wwe pay-per-view at monday
night raw at uh independent show for
ring of honor at at a
what looked like a hockey rink
in san antonio or something of the like
and at the biggest independent
professional wrestling show ever uh
in chicago in 2018
and
just knowing what it's actually like
behind the scenes
if i ever felt like anything was wrong
or anything didn't
didn't look right
i would speak up and the cool part about
heels is that
mike o'malley
pete siegel who's an ep but directed six
of the eight episodes or jessica lowry
who directed three and four
if anyone was ever not sure about
anything
i would be consulted
and it was you like that i love it i
love it i felt
like
for reasons that
i i think are obvious because of the
place that i was in my career when i
when i accepted this job
i am much more of a partner on heels
than i
ever was on arrow
how so just because of more of the
consulting well think about think about
when you were hired as as lex on
smallville
right
do you remember
approximately what you made
in your first year doing the show
money yeah money we don't need to talk
about this specific figure but yeah i'm
sure you remember
yeah i remember would you have done it
for free
for free yeah like if if you knew
if you could go back and you could look
at what smallville was and what it's
done what it what it what what it's done
and what it did for you
like when i when i got when i got aero i
know what i got paid in that first year
but i also know
that if warner brothers would was like
we want
eight hundred dollars
paid to us per episode and then we'll
start paying you next year
i'm like okay
right so you go on to that show
as
someone that they hired i came onto
heels as a partner
it's not a criticism it's not a
criticism of the priority oh it's just a
different but it's just a different
thing right they offered it to me
this show got green lit because i said
yes
so you just walk in with a different
relationship